♪
>> Tucker: SO THE RUSSIA
STORY IS JUST HUGE.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
THERE IS NOTHING MORE
IMPORTANT.
THEY HACKED OUR DEMOCRACY,
PUTIN IS IN CHARGE.
EVERY AMERICAN CARES.
WE KNOW THAT.
I DON'T KNOW HOW WE KNOW IT
BECAUSE THE NEW "U.S.A.
TODAY" POLL SHOWS THAT
LITERALLY LESS THAN 1% OF
VOTERS SAY THAT SO-CALLED
RUSSIAN MEDDLING IS THEIR
TOP ELECTION ISSUE FOR 2018.
CNN HASN'T SEEN THE POLL
OBVIOUSLY OR THEY DON'T CARE
BECAUSE TONIGHT THEY ARE
RUNNING SOMETHING CALLED
TRUMP AND RUSSIA A CNN
INVESTIGATION WHICH
DESCRIBES THEIR PROGRAMMING
EVERY DAY.
[LAUGHTER]
IT'S PRETTY HILARIOUS.
WE HAVE BEEN HEARING ABOUT
RUSSIA NONSTOP LITERALLY
NONSTOP FOR MORE THAN A
YEAR.
ALMOST NO INFORMATION HAS
COME OUT TO JUSTIFY THE
OBSESSION.
NONE HAS COME OUT TO JUSTIFY
THE CLAIM THAT THERE WAS
COLLUSION.
AND MOST AMERICANS ARE NO
LONGER INTERESTED IF THEY
EVER WERE.
SO WHAT'S CALLED ON HERE.
A FORMER REGIONAL DIRECTOR
FOR BARACK OBAMA'S
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN HE
JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
THIS IS CONFUSING TO ME
BECAUSE NORMALLY YOU WOULD
SAY LOOK, MAYBE THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THEIR
PROPAGANDA ARM IN THE MEDIA
DIDN'T EXPLAIN THIS WELL
ENOUGH.
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
THEY ACTUALLY WORKED REALLY
HARD TO MAKE THIS PALATABLE
TO UNPACK IT AS THEY SAY IN
THE MEDIA.
THEY HAVE BEEN RELENTLESS IN
THEIR PRESENTATION OF THIS.
AND PEOPLE STILL DON'T CARE.
SO WHY IS THAT, DO YOU
THINK?
>> WHY DO AMERICANS NOT
CARE?
>> Tucker: YEAH.
WOULD DO AMERICANS NOT CARE?
>> BECAUSE WE HAVE BEEN
HEARING ABOUT THIS FOR OVER
A YEAR THIS IS VERY ONGOING.
VERY LITTLE TRICKLES OUT
FROM AN FBI INVESTIGATION
BECAUSE MUELLER IS BUILDING
ACE CAN A.
HE HAS GOT LITTLE TID BITS
OF WHAT HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE.
THAT'S ABOUT IT AFTER
HEARING ABOUT THIS FOR A
YEAR WITHOUT MUCH
INFORMATION COMING OUT AS IT
SHOULD NOT STILL BUILDING A
CASE.
THERE IS NOT A LOT TO GO ON.
AMERICANS ARE MORE CONCERNED
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING AT
HOME WITH THEIR POCKETBOOKS.
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH THEIR
TAXES.
WHAT'S GOING ON, WHEN THEY
ARE GOING TO GET THEIR TAX
REFUNDS THERE IS A LOT OF
OTHER THINGS I THINK THAT
AMERICANS ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT RIGHT NOW.
>> Tucker: I THINK YOU ARE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THERE.
I AGREE WITH YOU COMPLETELY.
IT'S SORT OF INTERESTING.
YOU ARE SAYING WE DON'T
REALLY KNOW ANYTHING, SO WHY
WOULD THEY CARE?
AND YET THE NEWS COVERAGE IS
LITERALLY WALL-TO-WALL I'M
NOT OVERSTATING THAT.
I HAVE A BANK OF TVS IN MY
OFFICE.
I KEEP THE SOUND OFF BECAUSE
IT'S MASOCHISTIC TO TURN IT
UP.
I SEE THE SCREEN ALL DAY
LONG, IT'S ALL RUSSIA ALL
DAY LONG FOR MORE THAN A
YEAR.
IF WE DON'T KNOW ANYTHING,
WHAT ARE THEY TALKING ABOUT?
>> YOU KNOW, I WATCHED ABOUT
10 MINUTES OF RACHEL MADDOW
AND IT WAS LIKE AN
OBSESSION.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THE MEDIA,
YOU KNOW, ON OTHER NETWORKS
THEY ARE OBSESSED WITH.
THIS BUT THE PUBLIC DOES
IN THIS.
I TOTALLY UNDERSTAND WHY.
WE JUST DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
INFORMATION NOW.
MAYBE IT F. MORE INFORMATION
CAME OUT.
IF WE GOT THE NUNES MEMO,
THAT WAS A BIG STORY.
WE GOT THAT.
THE DEMOCRATIC MEMO DIDN'T
SEEM TO GIN UP AS MUCH
INTEREST.
BUT RIGHT NOW THE RUSSIAN
MEDDLING STORY JUST -- IT'S
JUST NOT REALLY RESONATING
WITH EVERY DAY AMERICANS.
>> Tucker: I'M BEING UNFAIR.
REALLY THE CORE CONCERN
COMES FROM THEIR PAY MASTERS
IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
WHOSE INTEREST THEY SERVE.
IT'S REALLY DEMOCRATS WHO
HAVE BEEN DRIVING.
THIS AND WE HAVE HAD A BUNCH
OF THEM ON THIS SHOW.
NICE PEOPLE.
>> YES.
>> Tucker: IF THEY DON'T
KNOW ANYTHING, WHY ARE THEY
SO OBSESSED AND WHY AREN'T
THEY TALKING ABOUT THINGS
THAT AMERICANS ACTUALLY CARE
ABOUT?
>> I WISH I KNEW.
I TAKE A LOT OF ISSUE WITH
MY OWN PARTY.
WE HAVE -- THERE IS A LOT
THAT WE CAN IMPROVE ON.
WE NEED A COHERENT MESSAGE
TO DELIVER TO AMERICANS
OTHER THAN JUST RESIST.
WE NEED TO BE GIVING THEM
IDEAS WHERE WE CAN MAYBE
IMPROVE THEIR LIVES OTHER
THAN JUST GIVING THEM, YOU
KNOW, PROMISES OF RESIST.
>> Tucker: IMPROVING THE
LIVES OF ILLEGAL ALIENS HERE
AND GIVING THEM CITIZENSHIP
AND VOTING RIGHTS.
I THOUGHT THEY SHUT DOWN THE
GOVERNMENT OVER THAT.
REMEMBER THAT THAT WAS THE
TOP PRIORITY OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
DO YOU THINK THAT'S A WINNER
IN 2018?
>> IT WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN A
WINNER FOR EITHER PARTY.
I THINK, YOU KNOW, HONESTLY
IF WE WERE TO TAKE APART
THAT ISSUE.
IT WOULDN'T HAVE HELPED
EITHER PARTY TO HAVE MASS
DEPORTATIONS OF YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO ARE IN COLLEGE, MAYBE
SERVING IN OUR MILITARY.
I'M A VETERAN.
I SERVE WITH SOME OF THESE
GUYS IN THE MILITARY.
SO, YOU KNOW, I DON'T THINK
THAT WOULD HAVE PLAYED FAVOR
WITH ANY, EITHER PARTY.
SO I UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN
THERE.
BUT, YOU KNOW,.
>> Tucker: NOT TOO MANY --
SERVED IN THE MILITARY,
OBVIOUSLY.
>> GOSH, I DON'T HAVE THE
NUMBER.
>> Tucker: I DO.
SERVED IN GANG ACTIVITY THAN
SERVED IN THE U.S. MILITARY
JUST TO PUT IT IN SOME
PERSPECTIVE.
>> I GET WHAT YOU ARE
SAYING.
I UNDERSTAND IT'S A
LEGITIMATE CONCERN.
I'M A PRETTY CONSERVATIVE
DEMOCRAT.
I'M MORE OF A BLUE DOG
WE PROBABLY AGREE ON SOME OF
THESE THINGS.
>> Tucker: YOU SHOULD TELL
YOUR PARTY THE RUSSIAN STUFF
IF WE FIND OUT TRUMP AND
PUTIN HAVE BEEN PLOTTING THE
TAKEOVER OF THE WEST FROM
THE HOT TUB THAT'S A REAL
STORY.
>> I WOULD ALWAYS SAY THAT,
YOU KNOW, THE PROTECTION OF
OUR WAY OF DEMOCRACY IS VERY
IMPORTANT SO I AGREE WITH
THAT.
>> Tucker: WE ARE TRYING.
>> LET'S JUST LET THIS THING
RUN OUT AND IF TRUMP GETS